[Music]
Memory Luca
The best of Argentina, Misco, Brazil,
Qatar
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] The
atmosphere of this World Cup is the atmosphere of
celebration and encouragement, and
so on. We do not see any sign of it, but we as fresh people are happy and happy. We see people who are new to this culture, and I mean, why?  We even see that they wear clothes, but let them
know that they want to celebrate at the same time. They would like to experience culture.
This, on the contrary, is a very beautiful thing. Of course, we are
between us in the field, and so we say that if you
see anyone, you mentioned it wrongly, or you know that
this is something new to him.  We can publish clips and
I find that we will edit them. Ghutra will edit them. This is
the opposite. This is a great thing. I mean, there is no problem.
[Applause]